okay
[Music]
I want to fly ah let's do this
yeah
you gotta force it to come out what do
you
you're a genius I know like what'd I say
yes oh did you know what was gonna
happen to my brother when you stuck him
with this world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to unchoose me
who said that systems
thank you
[Music]
that's eliminated
you think the government is going to do
when they figure out that some kid has
this military attack
it belongs to me
yeah that's more like it
love you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong my family that's what
makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks foreign
[Music]
birthday